where were you dying that you were stuck
on a boat oh yes um i was filming inside
number nine
and we were on a lake uh on a pedalo the
entire episode is filmed on a pedalo
and the the crew said to us before we go
out there
um make sure that you've been to the
toilet because once we're out there in
the middle of this lake
you're not going back for hours so make
sure you've been to the toilet
and i was terrified because my bladder
is the size of a walnut
so i went on amazon and i bought um some
adult nappies because i was so scared
i was so scared of being that one person
to go oh i have to go back sorry and
although everyone has to go back
so i went and i bought some adult
nappies and i thought i was getting a
pack of 12 but in fact i got a box of
500.
but i never deployed it i just want to
say i never deployed it okay
on the show and if you laid down the 450
that you've left yeah they're there when
you need them exactly that's what i've
got planning ahead
[Music]
you